Today for our expert interview,
we'll be speaking,
um,
with the sort of father of rat laughter research.
Doctor Jaak Panksepp.
He will share his thoughts on rodent emotions.
So he holds an endowed chair at Washington State University's College of
Veterinary Medicine and is an emeritus professor of psychology at Bowling State
University.
He received his phd from the University of Massachusetts and behavioral
neuroscience.
And importantly,
he is a world famous expert in aspect of neuroscience.
He employs a detailed understanding of basic emotional systems at the neural
level,
often using animal and human models.
In his research,
he specializes in understanding how fear,
social bonding and separation processes are organized in the brain.
He has published a remarkable 300 plus scientific articles,
Co edited a multivolume handbook of the hypothalamus,
as well as for emotions and psychopathology.
And he's the author of a text entitled aspect of neuroscience,
the foundations of human and animal emotions.
His work has received well-recognized merits,
including for example,
among many the NIH research scientists development award.
Um,
so we have a special pleasure today to speak with doctor Pan Panksepp on the
emotional life of rodents,
animal models of human brains.
So welcome Yak.
Thank you for speaking with us today.
Thank you.
Adrenaline.
What I wanted to start out with was asking you a bit about sort of where your
journey in the field began.
In other words,
what first got you interested in studying emotion?
Well,
I think go.
We all have emotional lives.
Any intelligent person is very interested in these mysteries.
May have been a traditional topic of conversation ever since we could talk.
Of course talking is not evolved function.
We learn how to talk.
So we had many different words for it,
but it became very clear to me when I first entered graduate school in clinical
psychology that there was not a conversation about the real nature of emotions.
And I realized at that point at the very beginning of the cognitive neuroscience
revolution that one really had to understand these,
that the neuroscientific level.
And really the precipitant for me was working in the back wards of a psychiatric
hospital when I was an undergraduate.
And seeing the people coming into the hospital in emotional turmoil and becoming
fascinated by this human drama.
So I wanted to be part of it.
And that light and undergraduate work,
the best route was clinical psychology.
But that was the day of behavioral modification.
And talking about emotions was not permitted.
Hm.
So since then,
I mean,
you've just pioneered whole field of research.
you've played this role in not only founding,
but coining this term aspect of neuroscience,
you know,
that we'll use so widely today devoted to understanding these emotional
processes through psychophysiological tools and being a founder of this field,
you know,
coming from a time where emotion was not a sort of,
uh,
allowable phrase.
I wonder,
you know,
as you see the field when it's emerged in sort of where it's come now,
what are some of the most fundamental discoveries we've made through an affect
of neuroscience?
I think gone are the most fundamental.
General principle
is an evolutionary one.
We will never understand emotions and human brains and minds on unless we take
an evolutionary approach and we have to envision the brain as any bopped or
again,
with many layers of development.
And uh,
if we don't bring these layers at development into the conversation,
we will be talking past each other,
which we've been doing ever since I entered the field of psychology has become
very excited about emotions,
but they're working at what I call the tertiary process level,
namely,
uh,
emotions that have already been processed by complex cognitive processing,
which were very skilled at,
that's a cortical function.
But practically everything in the Cortex is learned below that you have primary
processes,
behaviors,
call them unconditioned responses.
Things activate it by unconditioned stimuli.
They did not study those.
But there are a host of the emotional systems down in the brain that we share
with the other animals.
If you take an evolutionary approach,
you cannot avoid that conclusion.
And affective neuroscience started with that.
So you've got tertiary process on top that you cannot study in animals.
You've got primary and process at the bottom would,
you can't study very well in human beings and in between the two you have what I
call the secondary process,
which is learning and memory and all behaviorism was based upon having solid
tools for learning and memory.
That's very important,
but that's where the unconscious resides.
The unconscious does not reside at the bottom of the brain.
There you have aspect of processes and that is a very difficult lesson to
penetrate through the jungle of words.
So given you know,
you're talking is very important,
this jungle of words as you say,
I mean that may have gotten in the way of some of the most important insights
that that need to be brought out in this field.
From this sort of what breakthrough is would you like to see in this field?
Well first of all I think I would like to see everyone acknowledge that if we do
not take levels of control into account,
we might be talking past each other.
And I think everyone has to accept the data that comes from the animal research,
especially when it converges on very robust predictions for our own species that
we're all most interested in.
I certainly am.
I entered in clinical psychology for having the same and I realize that without
a foundational science,
things will not move forward,
including new medicinal development,
which we are very interested in.
So from my perspective,
one can ask,
what do we find that the foundation of the emotional mind,
and we know we find at least seven types of basic,
not basic,
I would call them primary processing motion,
a slightly different concept.
Namely,
we can produce coherent emotional behaviors by stimulating specific parts of the
brain.
In every mammal that has been studied,
this emotional display is instinctual.
It has autonomic components,
it has clear behavioral components,
and we're only putting garbage into the brain.
You're not just electrical stimulation.
Other wall socket brought down to very tiny micro amp levels and you get
coherence.
So that automatically means the coherence was built into the brain.
And the great right through of aspect of neuroscience is to ask,
does the animal like it or dislike it?
Is it good or bad?
I mean,
the behaviors [inaudible] would say the animal doesn't care.
It's just a puppet.
These are just actions.
There's no psychological content.
But you can ask the animal,
we're not arouse this emotional pattern in you.
Do you like it?
Namely you said a reward.
Do you dislike it?
Is it a punishment?
We've got the tools for that and there's a law of nature that for some reason we
were still neglecting and psychology,
wherever in the brain you activate an emotional process is always rewarding or
punishing,
period.
Hmm.
I mean,
I just think that's,
that's so true.
And I think many of these insights are ones that we need to really take with us
as we move forward in this field of affect of neuroscience,
which is now just,
you know,
expanding,
even exploding at fast,
you know,
proportions with lots of new tools and discoveries.
Um,
I wanted to turn to another really important part of your work,
which is where you've scientifically demonstrated something that a lot of people
may you believed wasn't possible,
which is the fact that rats can indeed exhibit laughter,
this kind of special chirp.
And I wondered if you could tell us a bit more about the supportive evidence
that you're really,
really insightful work has done that suggests that rats can laugh.
Well,
uh,
we,
we're looking for other clear primary process emotions and it struck us that
play might be one of those.
And we develop very rigorous procedures for the first time I study play in the
laboratory and it was wonderful,
you know,
the animals loved it and they became very resilient to depression.
Uh,
you know,
it was as powerful reward is food for hungry animal and uh,
it looks like our own children playing.
And uh,
at one point we started asking,
are there play vocalizations?
Now we know that rats communicate in the ultrasound range,
so private tours will not be able to detect them.
And Lo and behold,
with ultrasonic equipment,
the playing field was full of little chirpy.
Sounds.
And we called them play vocalizations and we studied them,
especially Brian Knutson,
who's now at Stanford.
And part of this project,
uh,
the playing field is full of these little sounds.
And Lo and behold,
one morning I woke up,
but I said,
what if that is laughter?
And it took years to come to this insight and I think it came from a dream.
So I immediately went to the laboratory.
Jeff Berg,
dark was waiting for me.
I said,
Jeff,
let's go tickle some Rach.
Okay.
Firsthand.
I'm all chirp like crazy when we tickled them is the second animal,
third animal.
We could bring this vocalization under stimulus control.
And now it's our primary measure of positive social,
an effect because Jeff and his dissertation,
not the system with deep brain stimulation and every place we were able to get a
Chirp,
the animals self stimulated that site.
So we have the first Dalat dated measure of social joy that's based on
neurocircuits as opposed to just theoretical speculation.
So in what way do you see that last year as similar or distinct from human
laughter will?
Uh,
it's homologous.
There's a evolutionary continuity.
Nothing and evolutionist identical.
A lot of people accused me.
How can it be identical?
That's nonsense talk.
Homology means there's the evolutionary relationship and there are bound to be
similarities in the mechanisms.
For instance,
the human brain contains no neurochemistries that are not present in the other
mammals.
So we are not unique at that level.
We're only unique because we have a enormous neocortex and a that neocortex is
empty at birth.
Everything is constructed there including vision.
The vision has to be learned in the NEOCORTEX.
So I'm a constructivist in the neo cortex,
but at the bottom of the brain we have to understand the instincts and the
instinct of laughter.
And humans appears to come from those same circuits.
You know,
people that have,
you know,
gymnastic,
uh,
there,
you know that it's caused by epileptic fits that is triggered down deep in the
brain,
very much in the areas of the brain that we mapped for rent.
Laughter.
So we think by working out the chemistries of rat laughter,
we will have new ideas for antidepressants.
Yeah,
I wanted to ask,
I mean,
what do you think this can tell us about what ways we can understand social joy
in molecular terms and develop as you're saying novel,
you know,
treatments like antidepressants?
Well,
what we did with my colleagues at Northwestern university,
you Joel Moscow's group,
uh,
we did micro arrays on the Neocortex,
which is not needed for play,
but which play influences play programs.
The neocortex for me,
a higher social brain.
And uh,
we found that the micro ray analysis yielded one third of the genes that we
measured being modified either up or down.
And we had very simple strategy,
whatever gene is upregulated.
And the top one was insulin,
like growth factor one might be a molecule that promotes social joy and insulin
like growth factor does the second one,
but it also increases cancers.
So it's not a good target for medicinal development.
But the second one was the NR,
two B subunit of the glutamate and glycine receptor complex.
And that is a target that doesn't have any medicines.
And Lo and behold,
we develop some molecules to tickle that site and it elevates 50 kilohertz
chirps,
which is what we want.
We want to antidepressant to elevate positive social feelings.
So we pursued that molecule first pre,
clinically namely animal research.
And it's now gone through human testing.
Well they went through phase one toxicology.
It was safe phase two a,
which was the first feasibility study and it produced robust anti depressant
effects,
namely have bigger effects sizes,
then the SSR i's,
which having enormous problems,
Ssri,
you know,
if you're on them for years,
you get addicted to them and you can't get off them,
which just makes it a wonderful money male.
Uh,
so we have a molecule on development and the whole philosophy of aspect of
neurosciences.
When you see the similarities of the animal than other mammals and the human
brain,
you're going to work out the details that you can never do when humans.
Wow.
So what do you think we can also learn,
um,
in terms of molecular terminology about things like sorrow and you were talking
about joy and the,
you know,
there's always sorrow as well as part of our emotional life.
That's a wonderful question.
I'm glad you asked it.
The cause,
the very first set of major that we did when we open up the Pandora's box of
bath backed across species neuroscience,
was to try to identify the brain systems that mediate social attachments,
the kinds of systems that Harry Harlow had shown,
how the motherless monkey is a very sad creature,
but it cannot function in the world.
And we thought it might be,
there might be a separation distress system in the brain.
And we said,
we can monitor this by looking at separation calls you separate little one from
the mother.
And Lo and behold,
we found a system.
Uh,
it's a very robust one in many mammals,
not laboratory rats,
by the way.
And that's a long story.
I'm,
a lot of people are making mistakes.
You know,
it's been bred out of a laboratory rat.
And,
uh,
we found first that it was modulated by endogenous opioids.
And we had this theory at social attachment isn't addictive process that many
people who have psychological pain because they're disenfranchised,
they don't have good social networks,
they're continually feeling bad and they start to self medicate themselves with
opioids because the rest of us then have happy families are releasing opioids
all the time during positive interactions like play and uh,
you know,
just hugging a love sex loss,
all the social positive things facilitate opioid activity.
So,
uh,
you know,
with demonstrated that this separation system actually has opioids around it and
touch activates that evening.
So,
you know,
little baby that's being cuddled,
you're releasing their opioids and you are producing a social addiction.
Addiction is a bad word there.
You know,
this little luck,
you know,
there's prime more evidence that opioids mediate love more than oxytocin.
Oxytocin also,
I was very effective,
but oxytocin increases confidence,
which every mother needs to have this baby coming and you don't have confidence,
you're not going to be a good mother.
So this is all really interesting.
I mean,
thinking about the field of aspect of neuroscience,
that you played such a fundamental role in founding,
you know,
transitioning to understanding social joy in the molecular terms of it and
studying it and in rodents and then now thinking about sorrow and how we can use
some of these insights to help to develop novel kind of targeted treatments.
When you think about sort of where the field started,
where it's come,
how do you project into the future in terms of thinking,
well,
what's in store for the future of emotion here
we'll,
I think a really wonderful aspect is that we finally can scientifically
understand the foundation of the human mind by studying other animals.
The animal research will not reveal how are upper mind works,
but if we take an evolutionary point of view,
we have to realize that what came first always rules.
You know,
these solutions for living,
that the primary process,
the emotions are constituted from these are foundational for learning and
memory.
So we had a law of effect Thorndyke we should now have a wall up aspect exactly
the way Thorndyke originally phrased it.
It's the aspect of circuits of the brain that control learning.
And we have to realize that these fundamental aspects are tools for living.
And the way nature saw projecting itself into the future is to generate the
spooky things,
call feelings,
aspects.
Neck tell you immediately whether you're on the path of survival or destruction.
So every good feeling indicates you're on the path of survival just
statistically and all the negative feelings tell you,
you might be on a path of destruction.
This is anticipating the future.
That is the function of bath back.
And then you anticipate through learning and memory.
So aspect controls,
learning and memory and learning and memory give you the tools for thinking.
You have to have facts before you can have ideas,
but the ideas or the creation of our higher mind and they can be anything we can
imagine.
And that's why there's so much controversy at the verbal level.
So if we accept the foundations,
we can have a clear discourse,
I believe.
So what advice do you give men to future students who are just thinking about
embarking the study of emotion or just getting into their first few years?
Well,
uh,
I think I would suggest that they need you read aspect of neuroscience,
1998 in a restaurant,
10 dozen years writing that book.
And I wrote it for other psychologists so they would be attracted to the
neuroscientific analysis and I just came out with archeology and mine and make
it a little bit simpler,
updated,
especially for clinicians.
And I was delighted the first community of psychologists who were interested in
it.
In this vision,
we're clinicians.
So that was very gratifying for me.
And I would say that every future generation of psychologist has to realize that
you cannot be a real psychologist unless you understand the brain and you're
able to navigate in your mind how the brain is organized.
That has to be the foundation of psychology.
I argued for this starting in the 19 seven days when we had the Utah Conference
on graduate,
but it still has not happened.
I don't think we can graduate psychology majors who have not taken neuroanatomy
and functional on neural processes that is foundational,
just like DNA was foundational for biology.
So it seems that what's most important is to truly understand the human brain
and for to understand anything about emotion.
I would say we cannot understand emotions without the brain analysis that does
not neglect or negate higher level analysis.
That is very interesting.
But remember,
every human being is interested in the higher part of it.
We would not have our,
we would not have theater,
music novels,
we would not had any of the riches of,
you know,
the arts,
which are so important to our lives without emotions.
But the arts are beautiful creations of the basic emotional tools that we have.
But the symphony finally is created by the full brain.
And of course we have the most rich and complex upper emotional life of any
creature.
Well,
on that beautiful note,
um,
I want to thank you for speaking today.
It was a pleasure to talk with you.
Wonderful to talk to you.
Thank you,
Joan.
Thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview series with Dr Jaak pants up
from Washington State University's College of Veterinary Medicine and emeritus
professor of psychology at Bowling State University.